.
THE DESTRUCTION BEING UNLEASHED
ON THIS COUNTRY DAY IN AND DAY
OUT.
MELISSA AND JEREMY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME IS IAN BREMMER,
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "THE
POWER OF CRISIS," THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
YOU PUT THIS BOOK TO PRESS FOUR
DAYS AFTER RUSSIA INVADED
UKRAINE.
BUT YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS
INCREASINGLY LOOKS LIKE WHAT YOU
CALL A GOLDILOCKS CRISIS.
EXPLAIN THAT FOR US.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
VIDEO WE WERE JUST SHOWING A FEW
MINUTES AGO, THE CULTURAL CENTER
BEING BOMBED, IT'S JUST
UNIMAGINABLE WHAT THE UKRAINIANS
ARE GOING THROUGH ON A DAILY
BASIS.
BUT WE'RE SO GRATEFUL TO HAVE
YOU ON TO TALK ABOUT THIS BOOK,
IAN, AND ALL OF THESE CRISES
THAT ARE SHAPING WHAT WE'RE
SEEING ON THE WORLD STAGE TODAY.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT, A
GOLDILOCKS CRISIS?
>> IT'S NOT A GOLDILOCKS CRISIS
FOR THE UKRAINIANS IN MARIUPOL,
THE CITY THAT'S BEEN DESTROYED.
IT'S NOT A GOLDILOCKS CRISIS FOR
THE 6 MILLION UKRAINIANS THAT
ARE NOW FORCIBLE REFUGEES LIVING
ACROSS EUROPE.
BUT WHAT'S CLEAR IS THAT NATO
HAD BEEN ERODING.
IT WAS A DRIFT, IT WAS
MISSIONLESS.
THE UNITED STATES BELIEVED THAT,
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT BELIEVED
THAT.
THIS IS EUROPE POST BREXIT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
PUTIN BELIEVED IT.
HE THOUGHT, LIKE IN 2008, LIKE
IN 2014, IF HE UPPED THE ANTE
AGAIN AND ROLLED INTO KYIV, AND
REMOVED ZELENSKYY FROM
GOVERNMENT THAT THERE WOULD BE
NO EFFECTIVE RESPONSE FROM THE
WEST.
HE WAS WRONG.
THIS IS THE WORST MISJUDGMENT BY
A MAJOR LEADER ON THE GLOBAL
STAGE SINCE THE SOVIET UNION
COLLAPSED.
AND FRANKLY, THAT HAS PROVIDED
AN ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY.
NOT ONLY FOR THE UKRAINIANS TO
FIGHT AND SHOW THAT THEY CAN AND
SHOULD BE A PART OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION BUT ALSO HAS ALLOWED NATO
TO GET STRONGER TO FOCUS ON
DEFENSE IN A WAY THE EUROPEANS
HAVE REFUSED TO FOR DECADES.
HAVE ALLOWED FINLAND AND SWEDEN
TO JOIN AND THEY WILL AT THE END
OF THE MONTH IT'LL BE APPROVED
AT THE MADRID SUMMIT.
AND I THINK MOST PEOPLE AGREE
THEY HATE PUTIN MORE THAN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHEN I WAS WATCH THE NANCY
PELOSI AND THEN THE MITCH
McCONNELL CONVOYS TO KYIV, THE
MESSAGE WAS IDENTICAL.
THIS IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY,
THE RULE OF LAW, AND THE ALLIES
AROUND THE WORLD, AND ALLIES IN
ASIA ARE NOT GOING TO STAND FOR
IT.
I CALL THAT A GOLDILOCKS CRISIS.
>> IT IS CERTAINLY A SILVER
LINING IN THIS, WE'RE SEEING
NATO COME TOGETHER IN WAYS WE
WOULD NOT HAVE IMAGINED A YEAR
AGO.
LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
FINLAND AND SWEDEN TALKING ABOUT
JOINING THE ALLIANCE.
IT IS REMARKABLE.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER OR NOT, YOU KNOW, THERE
IS CAUSE TO BE HAD, CONCERN TO
BE HAD ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS GOING TO STAND
FOR SWEDEN AND FINLAND TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, TO JOIN
NATO.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT?
THAT THIS IS A PROVOCATION, AND,
OF COURSE, OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
PLAY INTO -- DON'T WANT TO PLAY
INTO PUTIN'S HANDS HERE BY
SAYING SWEDEN AND FINLAND CAN'T
DO THIS.
I HAVE TO IMAGINE IT'S
INTERPRETED AS A PROVOCATION AND
THERE IS A RISK INVOLVED IN ALL
OF THAT.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR THAT THE
PROVOCATION WAS 190,000 RUSSIAN
TROOPS THAT ROLLED INTO UKRAINE,
AN INDEPENDENT SOVEREIGN
COUNTRY, AND PUTIN LIED DIRECTLY
TO THE UNITED STATES, THE HEADS
OF STATE IN EUROPE, SAYING IT
WAS A TRAINING EXERCISE, THEY
WERE NOT GOING TO INVADE.
IT'S A PROVOCATION THAT'S NOT
COMING FROM NATO.
I TAKE YOUR POINT.
AND, OF COURSE, WESTERN LEADERS
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
THINGS WILL BE PERCEIVED AS
ESCALATIONS BY PUTIN.
LET'S UNDERSTAND WHEN SWEDEN AND
FINLAND FIRST TALKED ABOUT
INTEREST IN JOINING NATO TWO
PLUS MONTHS AGO WHAT YOU HEARD
FROM RUSSIA WAS THERE WAS GOING
TO BE CONSEQUENCES WE'RE GOING
TO RAISE ON HIGHER ALERT.
IT WAS TRULY THIS BLUSTER AND
ESCALATION.
YET THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE KREMLIN MOVING
THE GOAL POST, IT'S NO BIG DEAL,
THEY'RE SMALL COUNTRY.
WE MEAN IF THERE'S NATO
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BASES PUT ON
THEIR TERRITORY, WHICH THE
FINISH GOVERNMENT SAID THEY HAVE
NO INTENTION OF DOING.
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE IS THE
RUSSIAN'S BLUFF BEING CALLED.
AND IT KIND OF MAKES YOU WISH
THAT THE INVASIONS OF 2008 INTO
GEORGIA AND 2014 INTO UKRAINE
WERE SEEN AS SUFFICIENT CRISES
THAT THE WEST WOULD HAVE
RESPONDED TO THE RUSSIANS THEN
AND THE PRECISE FACT IS IT
WASN'T.
IT WAS TOO SMALL WE COULDN'T BE
BOTHERED, WE HAD OTHER THINGS ON
OUR PLATE.
SO PUTIN THOUGHT HE COULD GET
AWAY WITH MORE AND MORE AND
MORE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY BECAUSE THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO DESTABILIZE THINGS
AS WELL IN WAYS WE CAN'T IMAGINE
AT THIS POINT.
WHILE AMERICANS PAY MORE FOR
GAS, FOOD, RENT, THE STOCK
MARKET IS FLASHING WARNING
SCIENCE WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN A
WHILE, THE DOW IS ON THE LONGEST
LOSING STREAK IN NEARLY A
CENTURY.
THE S&P 500 IS FALLING INTO BEAR
MARKET TERRITORY.
NOT A LOT OF GOOD NEWS ON THAT
FRONT.
AND THIS IS HAVING AN EFFECT ON
JOE BIDEN'S STANDING AS
PRESIDENT.
A NEW POLL SHOWS HIS APPROVAL
RATING AT 40%.
DEMOCRATS WORRY THE ECONOMY IS
GOING TO SINK THEM COME THE
MIDTERMS IN NOVEMBER.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU THINK
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS IN HIS UTILITY
BELT TO HEAD THAT OFF?
>> WELL, HE'S GOT ROE V. WADE,
WHICH, OF COURSE, THE
REPUBLICANS HAD A MUCH EASIER
TIME RUNNING AGAINST THAN
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR IT.
I THINK THAT MAKES THE SENATE
CLOSER IN THE IN TERMS OF.
BUT I MEAN, IN A GENERIC
CONGRESSIONAL POLL, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING SOME THREE
POINTS BEHIND THE REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW.
LOOKS LIKE A WAVE ELECTION.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, BIDEN HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY LESS CONFIDENT THAN
SOMEONE THAT TRUMP.
AND THAT IS A BAD PIECE OF NEWS.
WHEN I SAY THIS IS A GOLDILOCKS
CRISIS, LET'S BE CLEAR.
IT'S A CRISIS.
THE FACT IS THE INFLATION THAT
WAS ALREADY RUNNING HOT ON THE
BACK OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE
SUDDEN WHIPLASH IN MASSIVE
DESTRUCTION AND THEN MASSIVE
EXPANSION OF CONSUMER DEMAND ON
TOP OF ALL THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CHALLENGES AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT WE HAVE ZERO COVID IN CHINA
THAT IS NOT WORKING, SHUTTING
DOWN PORTS, SHANGHAI, THE
BIGGEST CITY.
AND NOW YOU HAVE RUSSIA VERSUS
UKRAINE, AND IT'S NOT THE
DISRUPTIONS CAUSED FROM THE
BOMBING IN UKRAINE WHICH IS A
MAJOR GRAIN AND FERTILIZER
PRODUCER.
IT'S ALSO THE MINING BY THE
UKRAINIANS OF THE BLACK SEA AND
THE BLOCKADE OF ODESA BY SHIPS.
THERE'S AN EFFORT TO NEGOTIATE
BETWEEN THE TWO SIDES THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET THE FOOD
AND FERTILIZER OUT.
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE MONTHS AT
A MINIMUM AND UNTIL THEN, WHO'S
GOING TO PAY THE COST?
CONSUMERS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
WE DON'T HAVE GOOD NEWS IN TERMS
OF INFLATION AND SUPPLY CHAIN IN
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE, JIM.
>> AND SO MANY OF THESE PROBLEMS
ARE INTERCONNECTED.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT MORE
THAN, YOU KNOW, THE TIME THAT WE
HAVE TO SORT ALL OF THIS OUT.
IAN BREMMER, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING